all right well I'm here with Miss
Burkina Faso and Miss Africa which is
excellent thank you so much for joining
us Georgie thank you so much for having
me crystal so to start can you tell me
about your foundation and the work that
you're doing in Africa absolutely
um so about the Georgian Padilla
Foundation I founded the organization in
2015 and uh one of the reasons that
actually inspired me to start the
organization is that as an African woman
I used to walk three hours to fetch
water with my grandmother and cousin
goats fetching water wasn't something
that I like uh you know I'm not the
morning person so every morning when my
grandmother was coming at the door she
would knock at the door shoes Georgie
let's go get the water
and
um all my thinking was like why it's so
early and why is the waterfowl why is
the water not near White where is our
water basically it didn't really make
sense to me as a child because water is
just so basic right it's a basic human
right everybody should have access to it
I was blessed to become Miss Burkina
Faso in 2003 following that I went to
miss Africa and God blessed me to become
Miss Africa following that I went to
Paris to start an International modeling
career and living in Paris was amazing I
have a great time being in Paris I could
take bubble bath anytime I want I could
flush my toilet I can even play flashing
metal don't do that don't do it but I
mean that I have plenty of water
available to me without even thinking of
what is capacity
back in 2009 my sister told me that she
was having a baby and that
that was a great news so I wanted to go
home to welcome the baby and celebrate
uh well Macon I have to watch my sister
waking up between 2 A.M and 4 AM to get
water
that is when I completely knew basically
nothing has changed yeah you know when
we were a kid we used to do that now
we're woman
my sister have to do that I I thought
that it was very important for me to use
my platform right because I don't see
myself as a better person than anyone
that I grew up with right but God has
blessed me so much is giving me that
platform so
why don't I use it so the thing that
we've talked about before is that in
your home country where your your
foundation is having the biggest impact
there's been a lot of unrest in the
country how does that impact the work
that you're doing with bringing clean
water to everyone yes uh so the Georgia
Barrier Foundation has
a student forces would knew the impact
uh so that we can hand the Water Crisis
in Burkina Faso we elaborated a plan to
bring clean water to every person in
rural Burkina Faso and at this time we
created this project called The Oasis
which is basically a community
place where the community gather
together to access clean drinking water
to have access to food and
toilet and sanitation also electricity
right because when I was a kid
unfortunately there were times that we
didn't have light in the villagers we're
like no light so for you to study uh
back in the days my mom used to use you
know the um the old school Game of
Throne uh petroleum
yeah okay yeah yeah we used to use that
and you know study with that and when
the petroleum is completely finished if
there was a candle she would light a
candle for us and unfortunately if
you're not done with your old work
you're gonna actually go outside and use
the one light
to study yes and how many times did you
have to do that well that's every day
every day
during my childhood and
um so it was very important for me to
create something that basically answer
uh most of the problem of the community
access to clean drinking water uh food
security uh toilet and sanitation access
to electricity we even have Outlet on
our Oasis where people can charge the
device ah real oh wow and how many Oasis
do you have so far we have been we have
built 10 Oasis okay and what we actually
do to actually sustain our Oasis is that
every time one person come to get water
they gave us the sum of 0.0 16 cents
okay which is basically almost nothing
um the funds are used to actually
maintain the water system because our
goal is to make sure that water is
interrupted in this communities and that
everyone have access to clean water
um just like I have in Paris and now
living in America so that's the dream
that's the dream amazing and speaking of
funds um can you talk to me a little bit
about how impact investing and ESG funds
from around the world are also helping
to contribute to the foundation yes
absolutely so new on one of the new the
impact of portofolio there is the sdg6
water and sanitation so anyone that come
in and invest in that partofonio a
percentage of the profit comes into the
Georgia Barrier Foundation which is used
to build this water system such as the
complete Oasis for communities in
but this is a new project that would be
piloting and uh it's been very much I
would feel promising talk to me about
the state of being an entrepreneur here
as a woman in Africa and what can be
done to help promote more of that oh
thank you
um I would say that
um again when we go back uh GBF has
built
um also this program called loan and
Grant
um into a program so that any Founders
that comes in that can actually
um give us a full Grant to build a Oasis
they have the option the Oasis is 20 000
they can give us four thousand in Grants
and then 16 000 in Lowell and the
community would basically pay back
through the 0.0 16 cents that is
collected at every Oasis last question
for you here what is your biggest piece
of advice for young women entrepreneurs
like yourself what would you tell them
oh I would tell them that
um it's definitely not easy to be an
entrepreneur
it's not easy uh sometimes I feel like
it's much easier to actually get a a
normal job right
um
eight to five best easy right but if
that's what you want if you want the
easy part of it then you go for it but
now if you have a dream that you want to
achieve you're gonna have to work harder
for and it's not going to be easy but
you can achieve it amazing well thank
you so much Georgie thanks for being
here